a priori rien d'extraordinaire en ce
vendredi quand même particulier quelques
embouteillages bien sûr et une présence
renforcée des forces de l'ordre mais
c'est en s'approchant de l'extrême
centre que la situation se complique
partout des barrages sortie autorisée
entrée interdite certains plutôt
optimiste prennent leur mal en patience
je travaille juste début de la grande
rue donc mais c'est pas grave je vais
faire le tour à vous pouvez contourner
oui oui c'est sans problème pour
d'autres pas vraiment de solution le
pont battant et coupez les tramways
bloqués pas facile de traverser le
centre apparemment à pied en vélo et pas
moyen de sortir de la boucle et voilà je
tends de rue après rue et non ça marche
pas je vais faire comment pas
aujourd'hui de chercher je vais réussir
à trouver un
si les crs font preuve de diplomatie
certains échanges sont tendues surtout
avec ceux qui travaillent ils nous ont
pas prévenus qu'ils allaient bloquer au
niveau de la grande rue au niveau de la
rue pasteur et au niveau de la rue
claude pouillé cette rue devait être
accessible
donc c'est complètement inadmissible ce
qu'a fait accessible seulement par un
passage couvert est désert huit salariés
80 repas prévu à midi apparemment
l'établissement devait se trouver hors
du périmètre
et c'est l'information qu'on a vu et et
les blocages de rue pour accéder à la
place de la révolution
mais en aucun cas pour accéder aux
commerces et encore hier pour nous la
place n'étaient pas verrouillées et même
les agents de sécurité du centre
commercial qui sont passés hier nous ont
dit que pour ouvrir et pas de souci pour
déplier terrasse y aurait pas de
problème ce matin des difficultés qui
devrait se résorber vers 14 heures le
président de la république sera alors
sur le chemin du retour